joe
has just lit
hello and welcome to this
press conference by the premier of quebec,
mr. françois legault, who is
accompanied by the minister of health,
mr. christian dubé, as well as the
national director of public health
ad interim, mr. luc boileau, i
remind you that  we have until 1:55 p.m. we are going to
take a question a sub-question
I give the floor first to our
interlocutors
yes hello everyone I
first want to talk about the situation in the
hospitals
we went over a week we
is at
3278 people hospitalized co-lead we
have today two thousand eight hundred and
fifty two people hospitalized
than visitors did when one
week we
reduced the number of people
hospitalized by 426 when we see that in
the last days the reduction  is
smaller than the previous days
so obviously
2852 it's still a lot of people in
our hospitals fortunately the employees are
starting to come back  those who were
absent we were at 12000 last week
miranda 10600 but we must never
forget that we all have to do the catch-up for
surgeries too so it's not
easy we had a tank last night and a
long discussion with public health
in  steel to weigh the shoulder and count
it is to balance the disadvantages
it is sure that on the one hand we want to protect
our hospitals it is still a lot of
patients 2850 of the water side we see that
the impatience of the  Quebecers who are
years old and I would even say
there is a question of mental health and
even social peace we see the discontent is
growing day by day so I
remember it the week people had
said if in practice done since yesterday the
restaurants have started to open again  their
dining room
extracurricular sports activities
in schools CEGEPs
universities we are starting again and I want
to clarify this effect
during the week it also concerns
artistic activities so I  some
who do dance improvisation
all artistic activities it's
in the same way as sports so that
's already allowed next Monday as
we announced the performance halls the
places of worship will be
able to
start under certain conditions  to reopen
and the question that comes up a
lot that we have discussed a lot
is that in a context where the
population or a good part of the
population is stressed, I think that
sports and artistic activities
for adults we must take a step  this
side so I'm pleased
to announce that from February 14th
so here's a record that comes the other
Monday sports and
artistic activities will be allowed for
adults up to a maximum of 25
people that means  also that the
jims won't slip will also be able to open
so on February 14 I'm thinking of doing
good but we're going to stop there
unfortunately we can't
announce other relaxations for the moment
seems to us  be able to do so
in the coming weeks, but it is
important, I say again,
to be careful, among other things, because of
the situation in our hospitals,
if only to come and support
the employees who have been at the front for
two years, which could  help us
speed up deconfinement it's the
vaccination
if we take the vaccination for
adults 18 years and over it was good
first dose 92% second dose 90%
third dose for adults we
got to 61% it  is not enough we have to
find the way stone of the place there
are vaccinators available
available doses absolutely necessary
to ensure better
vaccination coverage increase this
61%
now I want to speak
to people who have not been able to get
their first dose
I  first want to tell you that I
understand some people
we do not see it in a good light to
get vaccinated to have a product in
their body even if the experts are
almost unanimous on  almost
no side effects there are
hundreds of millions of doses that are
given in the world so it was to test
and
well the figures are also very very
clear
if you are not vaccinated you have a
much better chance of you
end up in the hospital than even much
more likely to die from the hill
so it's these places and I understand that
in a society like
ours freedom is a fundamental element
of our society but you have to understand
that freedom  of some stops where
the freedom of others begins and when
a person ends up in the hospital
with the empty COA but they take the place
of another patient cata for a
surgery for which a question of
solidarity is not  just a decision
that's
personal that's individual
and i want to really
reach out to the unvaccinated first
lyonnais today kern has put together a team
a great team that is in the process
of identifying
the 4.6s in different  regions of  in
quebec, where there are better vaccination rates,
there will be loeb teams which sees a
compound of vaccinators two people
who work from a clsc in the gmfs
of medical students from
community organizations so brigades that
will go to the  in front of the population
those who have difficulty
moving around we even go to the expense of
vaccinating at home it has already started
in a week
this work has made it possible to reach
about twenty thousand people, therefore
11,000 who are vaccinated  then 9000
who made an appointment so that
means we went from 547 mid to 5,127
miles then we hope in the next few
days the next few weeks will see this
figure there
is reduced then also I want to say to
all the people who  have
concerns who have questions you
can call 8 in 1 at any time
then there will be someone who will
answer your concerns your
questions now when we see
what is happening in our s  society when we
see what is happening in our
social media well I have a certain
concern to see Quebecers dividing
the Quebec people have always been a
people who have come together who are united who
love this center is important to
protect  its values then my role as Prime
Minister yes it is to ensure the safet
of Quebecers but it is also to en
ure a certain social peace a cer
ain social cohesion so my role
s Prime Minister is to bring
Quebecers together and  a
few weeks ago I announced that we were
going to table a bill to
set up a
health contribution for people who, without good
reason, refused to be vaccinated
the idea was to set up an
incentive and the project  of law is ready
the Minister of Finance prepare it a
mule time to discuss it but I
understand that this announcement there
came to divide the Quebecers I am
of course also the
opposition parties is against  this
health contribution
so to move quebec forward in
a calm social climate I am announcing
that the government will not table this
bill on the health contribution
I think that in Quebec
it is one of rebuilding bridges between
Quebecers c  it's time to reach
out for two years we've only been living through a
historic crisis in all
crises like that there are marks there
are scars and now the sector is
working together it's time to
come together so that  Quebec remains
a place where they boo today is good to
live for some beak remains a people
who punish whom I call on everyone
let's put a little water in our
wine let's try to talk to each other and try to
bring Quebecers together
skin  is able eventually to turn
the page on this historical crisis
expensive grafton -
continuous hospitalization of the budgetary crises
of the order which rots
does not aspire to the eight cellars of
greenwatt my
coming back on the stre  ss have
disapproved innauer aspire to boots
weekend fourguette de twister have long
way to go to restart surgery that have
been delayed we have to remain careful
what we also have to balance date 8
hours natural n 8 hours sochaux as
cohesion is impressive to wait
fred-barry footing sports
group all three deny five pipeau james
and spa or smiled at the affected countries
no one to pass the waves
vaccination is what kills facelift -
restrictions we're sexy all 6 3% havas
doors aggressive de todos we have to
increase of this very hot from tarnos very
important to protect ourselves games at the
micro also have made for people who have
received
dozier
experte tales of very nature more likely
to go to from azpiroz and daughter of lord of
the vaccine or i want you to explain from
risk
continue to try to readers
are
about the noise
and people
because
we need to build bridge to
thank you we are now losing
the questions it remains very accurate  ment
forty minutes so a question of
these questions I remind you that we are an
issue of time I give the floor to marie
michèle if so hello to all three
Mr. legault did you lack
judgment when you mentioned the
health contribution for a few weeks
but  the idea is to find all
sorts of incentives so that people
who have not been vaccinated get vaccinated
the vaccine passport is a means
health contribution could be a
means but I think that in the balance
today  I think it is important to
protect social peace closely to
protect social cohesion to
bring together Quebecers whose
health contribution I think could have
helped to be an incentive for some
people it would bring back an
overflow that is
not necessarily constructive in
the national assembly when  we see that
the opposition parties are responsible so I
think that currently we must
concentrate on convincing more
Quebecers of this fact to be vaccinated  then we
must also focus on continuing
to improve our health network
you talk about more important social peace
then the discontent
that existed three and a half weeks ago
the discontent what has changed
since that time the is what  that the convoy
of freedom
influenced your decision well listen there
I actually had demonstrations
ottawa there are some who want to come and
do some next days here in quebec
we see a growing discontent I
obviously saw the reaction of the
opposition parties so I think that I
also have a responsibility beyond
protecting the safety of Quebecers by
encouraging Quebecers to be vaccinated
I also have a responsibility
that everyone learns to live
together again we don't want Quebec that
divided  on the one hand 90% of Quebecers
higher than in Q1 10% of Quebecers
simon bourassa new yes hello
gentlemen
the yab evening per action what are your
receipts the most apparent bouallou who
denounces the deposit of the  mask at all
times for young hockey players
it is when they have gone strong
during practices that we can be explained to us
what justifies this
scientifically we must look at the
mask violates
the micron currently is much more
transmissible than viruses
saras scoville that we had
before the delta in particular the
African kit but really more
transmissible so when we are
close we breathe hard since
more risks of transmission we of
course avoid young people and even adults their
possibly to wear  a mask
ideally a procedure like
this one which is very effective and which
reduces the risk of transmission so
of course if at very intense activities
which are which are done well we
understand that we could not
wear it but  for the protection of
children and young people and adults
also between them it is important to
wear the basque thank you support and
tell me how you see the future  naked
potential of this convoy between high and
the truckers of ottawa and people from
the coast not also who could
come could we see you for
example tried to enter into dialogue
with these people there to appease the great
listen and I think that in our
society
the right to demonstrate is an
important right Quebecers the citizens
right to express themselves obviously it must
be done with respect then not with
null symbols so obviously we
hope that it will be done in the
respect now for that he
met ugly people always
available to meet people who
are in good faith to try to see
how we can help them with
their questions their concerns to
the effort
hello to all under the prime minister
the polls currently show
no dropout in terms of
health measures you backed off on the health tax
what you believe will be
enough to appease this frog
who is  t more and more ambient is
more and more strong that
the balanced is more and more difficult
to find it is sure that after two years
it is more difficult than in
March 2020 when we started to
face  to this pandemic there
are people who are fed up it's normal
after two years that's a bit why
we say today
we are not tabling the bill
on the health contribution what we
hope is  to be able to announce
two relaxations in the
coming weeks but at the same time
can't work miracles, you see
like me, the situation in our hospitals
can't take too many risks we have to
think about the employees we have to think about all
the Quebecers who are waiting for  a
surgery that was postponed so there
are miracle solutions sport
we vote for it we
know that a lot of collective humility
is dying out,
particularly in montreal one of the
major concerns of employees
over the last few years  1st rules is
when someone is to reach the
coved who still finds himself in contact
with someone from the empty aco here zé luis
isolates skin
i apologize someone who has been reached
with the bray shrimp and  who find themselves
in contact in an xyz period again
with someone who tests positive
do these people have to start the
process again
tomorrow or not look at what we know
is that when someone does
comedy is going to develop a
military capacity obviously six sets it will come
out of that with a
strong capacity for the other
exhibitions kg romaine virus the microphone
for a certain number of weeks
not infinite that it will last a certain
number of weeks so for sure if
we just come  to make the copy
for barely a few weeks and that we
are called to be isolated we may not
be isolated so the people who that is
to say who have been in contact day
from the answer but someone who would have
been in contact with  someone who is
doing the coved and who himself
paulhe the coved takes place for a short time his
need to be isolated is rather weak
hugo lavallée radio canada yes hello to
all sir first i would like to come back to
the question that was asked  everything
went asked if you had lacked
judgment which you recognize that
it was a mistake on your part
to mention
104 weeks
we obviously wanted but
incentives for more people to get
vaccinated for three weeks
the discontent has risen to the  quebec and
therefore the accounts of sos must always have
a balance that is fragile has
never been black or white from the discussions
that we have that public health
also leaves worrying about mental health it
has evolved then the balance must be
tried  to keep it then bin me what
I also wish is that
in the next few weeks
we put lass is the fifth wave
behind us then there we have to think about
the future we don't need his thought to
gather  Quebecers since the 10
% live with the 90%
you spoke about
vaccination earlier then you reached out to
those who have always received only one dose
of vaccine but on the other hand when we
look at the number  total doses
injected I think we are at 52 e mail
yesterday we are far from the
potential capacity in 5 11 year olds to sting at
62% for a first dose in the
general population for the third
dose it is not yet the  half of
the entire population because there
are specific measures for young people
the five have increased the rate of 62%
increase the third dose
generally
I complete need it is clear that if the
population
benefits from the dose of  reminder we will
be in a much better position
everyone to confront the
halls at the micron which unfortunately has gone
micron which can also change the b2 b12
which is on the rise in the world
so it is certain that it will arrive in
Quebec  and who will know aus  if its
expanding and who just want to be more
contagious so let's get the
booster dose there are still two million
people of adults who as it has been
mentioned that they have not benefited
from the booster dose it is important it
improves  their own
situation the sapwood situation had of course but
for their own situation it changes
enormously the capacity to be confronted
with this virus there and therefore it is important
really important to go and get
it as soon as possible and for those who
will have  made the coved recently we were
talking about it a few moments ago to
please already make their appointment
for the month of February where the
month of March to April to wait eight
weeks after their infection
it is completely correct eight  at twelve weeks
but they need this booster dose
is therefore the guests to immediately
make the appointment to
register well in their journey to
ensure that their immunity will be solid
and able to be  re built confronted with
the micro or its cousin the br 2
the convoy which could come to Quebec
is what worries you since
you discussed with the security of
the national assembly to increase security for example
I think that given the deductions of  my
office with the people that what full
of security so on that side its
covered now what I
worried you listen to me I hope it will
be done with respect yes people in
Quebec we have to show it  but it
must be done with respect I
think Quebecers expect
it to be done with respect the sub
boileau is what the prime minister
the ministers someone open from the
government sorry asked for your
opinion on  the health contribution what
is it you were asked no first of all
I'm not deaf to the game there I hear
about it but no one asks me my
opinion on this and nini for
arrivals nor for what comes
from  to be announced
or  i la croix cogeco hello Mr.
Prime Minister Mr. Minister
of Cornwall where
you have said Mr. Legault
several times in fact we know that a
change of tone in your approach
to the unvaccinated tells you I hope
that the  demonstrations of this weekend in
celebration which is coming it will be done
with respect
me I listened you may have
heard rambo gauthier today who
will be part of this demonstration there he
is one of the organizers he  comes
here first do you think that
in the time he uses it can be
done with respect and
have you backed
down from the threat of rambo gauthier
no link between rainbow taste too
since you announce today
obviously when a demonstration
degenerates it is several people in
his pockets one person I
trust Quebecers
I think that it is important to keep
this right to demonstrate is important
to do it in  respect and I
expect it to be done with respect
yesterday the leader of the conservative party
mr duhaime said at a
press conference and it was taken up in roughly
the same terms today by
which the st pierre  plamondon that we
can't make a whole people pay
excuse me for 223 people who are
in intensive care that's what
mr d'huy says put a mr st
pierre plamondon this morning says it
's not normal  that we make
all of a people pay for it because we
have too many people in the hospital will you
react when you hear
comments like these in the case
of the conservative party of quebec sq not
surprised in the  case of the Parti
Québécois surprised two said that we have
no right to put incentives
so that people get vaccinated could
avoid clogging our hospitals that
surprises me it's not the Parti Québécois
that I know then when I  hear the
parti québécois then even québec
solidaire says tantô  t that according to had too
many restrictions well I find it
irresponsible
marc andré gagnon journal de québec
bonjour bain precisely to appease
the grumbling which is increasingly felt is
what the relaxations there which are
promised for February 14 what
could be moved forward I  don't know me
for example on February 11
because there we still don't have any of them
just for news of possible
relaxations with regard
to white races private gathering or
unlimited anyway to four people
two bubbles the day before the  14 and an
important event you know is
the super bowl we see the stadiums which
are packed so
are there other relaxations that
could come sooner well listen eyes
nothing excluded what  what we did last night
is that we looked with public health
with experts from the two
institutes what are the projections
we have for the next two
weeks
we have chosen to be cautious is the
week  groin next we can tell you that
we could go a little further
for the day of the super bowl it's
part of the discussions in the fall
but beyond beyond that for
the moment it's no but we will
reconsider  all next week
boileau maybe on this to find out
for which full coach no no no no the
fact no but would be the reasons which
motivate why in fact we are
still in the same logic it is that
the micron is very contagious we  said it
several times and avoiding progressing
too quickly will allow
us to ensure the
solidification of the health system which
is a
collective well-being and everyone is
called upon to use it on a day when water for
all their loved ones  so you really have to
protect your stone right now even if
it's better it's not going well yet
so for
the super bowl or activities that
could be announced or already
measures that could be taken before
we're going to continue  looking at the evolution
of the health system and also the evolution
of the third of these people will
look for it, it means that we will be
able to go just faster and more
solidly towards a complete relaxation of the
measures
concerning us  space that
invite you in turn quite clear
to me so it's possible to take
off your mask when you make a
little more intense effort what does that
mean as much by our football or
hockey or  basketball c6 or we
draw the line be more precise simple
look there is a question of
judgment inside this pawn i
think people can wear a mask but
can also use their judgment and
the coaches and the  parents also it is
certain that we recommend wearing a
mask at all times at school includes one
for extracurricular activities and and even
at the secondary level of course and for
civil activities or six which will
occur goods but it is obvious
that if we have very c  haud that we do an
intense sport that we are on the ice for
example we could remove the mation 5
more comfortable to remove the mask
but when we find ourselves on the bench the
same if we are out of breath and then we
are next  colleagues or friends it
would be better to be able to wouldn't
just be better it would really be what you
have to do is to continue to wear
your mask as much as possible
tommy chouinard the a13 yes hello
first of all sir dubé you  you
declared
in January to leave it under January 7 that
it is clear for you not to pass the
vaccine will pass to three
doses do we not want this decision
it is the application of this
measure
I always choose to say  then you will
remember that we couldn't put
two dates in the first place because we do
n't know when people see me as
an opportunity
to get this 3rd 12 so so I
think it's really too early
because there are  limitations people
know the doc  the ball or the talk
the famous eight-week deadline so
therefore me for the moment I think that it
is still too early to look at
what would be the new
conditions of the vaccine passport for
the moment these two bronzes and when we
will have had all the  information and that
people will have been able to take the third dose
good to come back to it
you say the population must
take information on this subject I think
that we have several of them who are confused
about the option because the
people who have  been infected in
the last few weeks whose who made
the disease because of the var ya handed over kron
the experts the they don't get along at
all the you had I play his youth
in an instant because you said at the
start an early January as soon as  the end of the
symptoms as soon as possible
go and get vaccinated then we
finally come press release issued on
Friday afternoon in ten years and not as soon as
possible finally respected including the
minimum deadline that we say  of therefore from
eight weeks it is the case we look
from eight weeks the ideal d but between
the real ideal time these three months and
on the other hand when we look at the life
of the dry cycle which supposedly the one who
is responsible for advising you in  the
part of the vaccination campaign says
it's better to wait for the new vaccine
you have to believe in who exactly
sir chinese I'm really
happy that you leave this question
there because I'm going to pass the floor to
doctor boileau but before I you  tell me
why it's important that it's him
who answers me yesterday a person from whom
we receive an opinion that will impact
our judgment it's the director of
public health who sees him from
different organizations this Thursday except
many times that  'we could always say the
same thing that there is a group that we
listen to this doctor boileau but for
that I will leave you explained
we thank you very much for the
trust but you know it well I can
not  not have all the science so
we will look for it everywhere we need to and in
particular at these places so that we say
exactly the same thing if there is
confusion in the message it is good and we
want time because the signal is
the same we must take advantage the third
dose went to get in large
numbers as quickly as possible of course
for people who have had an episode
of kobe documented with a pcr test in
the pcr screening centers or do
we have any  pcr tests and they have
done can wait an 8 to 12
weeks to get their back
but he should register right away
to be able to make sure they have
the appointment to benefit the
other curious ones
kfw-related disease who have had a positive test but
who are really hits who have
really had a viral syndrome who has who
is related to the commune can
also wait eight to twelve weeks
but in the code of doubt you must not
hesitate to  go look  r this third
dose the first because it does not have
any side effects or risks
for people who have been
infected recently without her
not knowing what there is by the way of the
people they have done  and who are
asymptomatic so
also go get the third dose on this side but
is safe and above all to ensure that
our immunity is at full speed if we
have we are called to be confronted with the
virus could call being confronted with the
virus has  says that it is of little use
and suggests that she wait for the new vaccine
being the one that can protect like
pariahs like a microphone the president of the
ciq is doctor caroline couach who
is an expert with a very high reputation
like the members as dry  and I
spoke to him several times years speaks
regularly and we are aware that
eventually there will be another vaccine
which will arrive and we thought that it
would arrive sooner but in all
likelihood it true not including four
Indians  and others 2 he especially
seduced them the postponement we are better off going
with the Indians who are currently having the
third dose and doctor
couach is completely comfortable with
the idea that we encourage the  third
dose for everyone those who have
made the cover and documented excess
can wait eight to twelve weeks
but registering for the benefit of
this booster dose is the action to be taken
now if you
allow me I will  ask the question
patrice bergeron mr dubé you
personally even before
there was discussion on it
were you in favor of the question of a
health contribution
listen i think that these are
discussions that we have internally in
our  groups i, like all
my colleagues, have always
supported the decisions we have taken
so i am very comfortable
with the decision announced by the
prime minister today
moreover it was it is often
discussed  of the AC  hospital pacity of
quebec therefore in your future plan felt
therefore there will probably
be an increase in
hospital capacity it should amount to
combiers according to you the optimal capacity
I am I am very happy that
you are interested in the plan that we are going to table
in a few weeks would ask you
to be patient to give all
the information on these issues and
when we testify if we are less
patient
listen I will tell you that it is coming
we are working on it I think we
learned a lot from the pandemic and I
think the recommendations for me
now are going to be very clear so
that we never again find ourselves in the
position known today we
are now the pair of the questions
in English we will start with
sir son tools  of gas is listed
it's many
experts
so right now is
able
structure to manila projects in other
because the may 12
date is not set for an art
or a sau  this
anglophone so right thing that if we
have to choose priorities and xpand frankfurt
has capacities
but
you
have to know it's the trio
nomination 9 10 deputies ministers to this
morning from where is helping these young people
explodes toulouse millions of dollars the
project so what was a very hot rods
of these young people was taken by two
romanian and serbian ministers
yes well listen to the reasons why
we chose
to delay the
dawson expansion project it's because there are a lot of
two projects in
francophone cegeps first it is important to remember that
teenagers are only 50% of students
who are anglophones and we think that
currently when we choose
priorities it is preferable to first
proceed with the expansion of the cegep
francophone
[Music]
from computing to linfen
from challenger we want you to die
for
each other parts is a double system
nor to take a by tomtom room all mac
do things and without
significant increase is due to
dakar
nzb holdin  g both doctors and i
think that this morning wyatt of 100 to
hear about the perception of the
perception of the world as we tried to
do what would provide
and resistance systems
of the scribes and normand
games
the duplicate or process score
of
all
[Applause]
these young people
they
will know yes but ska to recommend
snec said
michael
cerenzie at the microphone of eric in test-match
died of one of the three jumps
and
michard debt and will not in sweet
mathematics
possibility of keeping  from contex new
world and he was before and weight
vintage swing band
and on the other between
[Music]
and 10 years old guy paul side
swimmer and your
[Music]
points
waterfront pipe the streak
direct bullets contribute not ability to
note bo bling  because we thank you
des bb 29 6 2
500 ft
new skin remains in good condition and
lighting it's about time that we for
October and that I suggest a donation was to
see
the thigh she the thigh à la swica nana
ce  tweak sans pipe organizers pippo a
whose date a thing yes we have to make
sure of a protect the art of cobac a
good advance or to protect the pixel our
society
sobac tracking
webtaxes because you feel or
0.6 and we
unite the case  type hysteria oh
yes that date came from the stars of
pandemic
wiiware
one kind of time
3d accepts vaccination foam why
is because we
solidarity and sport value was in
washington
but big data
by
force we have to balance
was doing kate and  mentoring
of any
object
since january of ten
describes this number is hospitalized in sion
of wazzan increase in die vaccination
she nor her
exit from the wii corso of running crisis
in of reaction to pipots
death of never saw what i'm trying to do
esteem balance  between
physical
m between 1 and analyze young people
evolve slowly
it is in
fact
it is
a mask and 22
may
risk
of a context defense of his flock
some of them and I receive my likely to
be really be for ever  is because avis
- oh yes you know at risk to be
compared with
free
that's what this
press conference did to me thank you
in collaboration and your conciseness